I gotta check this out MySQL is the most
popular database flavor in the world
how are you millions of WordPress blogs
and large complex enterprise
applications today you'll learn how to
combine cloud functions along with
Google Cloud SQL to build an entirely
server list cloud database and we'll
combine it with an awesome tool called
type o RM which will help us efficiently
model in query relational data using
nothing but typescript and nodejs
if you're new here like and subscribe
and congrats to Fabian how listen you're
the t-shirt winner from last week's
video
send me your details on slack and if you
missed out just leave a comment below
because I'm giving away another t-shirt
with this video let's go ahead and start
by addressing the obvious question of
why would you ever want to use a MySQL
database with firebase the platform
already has fire store which is a fast
and expensive database that scales out
of the box while fire store will take
care of the majority of your relational
data modeling needs there may be times
when an SQL database is just the better
tool for the job
or you might just be working with a
legacy database where you have no choice
in the matter no matter what the use
case my goal today is to show you how
easy it is to integrate mysql with
firebase the first thing you'll learn is
how to provision a cloud SQL instance
and then how to connect it to the cloud
functions environment the second big
thing you learn is how to use a tool
called typo RM which provides object
relational mapping with typescript and
this allows us to completely manage our
database structure and queries without
ever having to write a raw SQL query and
using a tool like this will dramatically
increase your productivity and developer
happiness the feature we're building
today is a collection of HTTP cloud
functions that allow us to read and
write to the database our database
contains a hippo table and those hippos
can own many hats but the hats live in
their own database table so we'll need
to build a join query to join all that
data together into a single request
you'll need a few things to get started
with this project first you'll want to
have a firebase or a Google cloud
platform project and then I highly
recommend you have a rest client like
insomnia or postman or the rest client
plugin for vs code so we can make
requests to the cloud function endpoints
after we deploy them from there we'll go
ahead and open an empty directory with
the s
and then run firebase event functions
from the command line you want to select
typescript although it is worth noting
that it's possible to use Type O RM with
vanilla JavaScript if you prefer that
will generate a functions directory so
we'll go ahead and CD in there and then
install type ORM reflect metadata and
MySQL from there we'll jump into the
automatically generated TS config and
make a few updates we'll set strict mode
to false and enable experimental
decorators as well as their metadata and
one last thing I'll mention is that you
want to make sure you're running
typescript version 3.5 or greater so
double check that in the package JSON so
that takes care of these setup for cloud
functions now let's head over to Google
cloud platform and create a MySQL
instance but first I'd like to point out
that this is not a free service on GCP
the smallest SQL instance will cost
about seven dollars per month but I
actually think that's the lowest price
that you'll find on any cloud and your
build by the second so you can pause or
resume it at any time we can create the
instance by going to the SQL tab on the
GCP console make sure that you select
MySQL because the setup is slightly
different for Postgres you'll want to
make a note of the root user password
and then when you get to the instance
details page you'll also want to copy
the instance connection name now one
thing to keep in mind is that this
instance isn't just a single database
it's multiple databases pulled together
along with a bunch of other fully
managed features like automated backups
and logging and all that good stuff
if you're building a real app you likely
want to have at least two databases one
for development and then one for
production for your live customer data
so go ahead and create those on the
databases tab and I'll show you how to
connect to them automatically based on
the environment when we get to our
functions code so now that we have a
cloud SQL instance we need a way to
connect to it in our local development
environment the easiest way to handle
this is to download the cloud SQL proxy
this is just a convenient way to connect
because it means you don't have to worry
about IP addresses or SSL to connect to
the instance go ahead and download it
into the root of the project then run
this command from the command line just
make sure to replace the instance
connection name and hopefully everything
went well and it says ready for new
connections go ahead and leave this
terminal tab open because we want this
process running in the background while
we do everything else the next thing
we'll do is create a config PS file in
the source directory the purpose of this
file
is to handle the connection to the
actual database and also to switch
between our development and production
databases depending on the environment
and we also need to import reflect
metadata for type o RM that just gives
JavaScript some better runtime type
checking capabilities then cloud
functions has an environment variable
called node underscore env it's
undefined when you're working locally
but when you're in production it's set
to the string of production so we can
use that to switch between our
production and development databases
from there we'll set up an object for
the connection options and then I want
to point out a few things that I've
modified specifically for the cloud
functions environment first you'll want
to make sure to point it to the
development database and then you'll
want to set synchronize to true when
you're in development now normally with
an SQL database you need to create the
database tables and then migrate changes
whenever there's a change but one of the
magical things about type ORM is that it
can handle all this stuff automatically
now I would like to point out that it's
not always safe to use synchronize in
production but it's a super useful thing
to have during development in a few
minutes we're going to write some
classes called entities and those get
compiled to the Lib folder and that
takes care of the options that we want
for the development database and most of
those will be the same in production but
there's a few things that we want to
override if that node environment
variable is set to production and we can
easily do that by conditionally merging
in an additional object with the spread
syntax we'll go ahead and point it to
the production database and you may want
to set synchronize to false but we'll
leave it enabled for now and then we
have this extra option here called
socket path which will point to cloud
sequel slash or instance connection name
now that gives us a configuration object
to connect to both a production and
development database and now I'm going
to write a function called connect that
will actually make the connection or use
an existing connection designed to
optimize the use of the database in the
cloud functions environment the
interesting thing about cloud functions
is that they're short-lived and the
resources are provisioned on demand but
it is possible for a database connection
to be shared between the functions so
we're creating this custom connect
method in order to check for an existing
connection by the configuration name but
if that connection doesn't exist then
it's going to throw an error so we'll go
ahead and catch the error then create a
new connection based on our
configuration options so this should
help us optimize the response time of
the function
and limit the number of connections to
the SQL database because that is a
finite resource now we're ready to get
into the fun stuff starting with our
entities and type ORM an entity is just
a typescript class that maps a database
table to your code so simply think of an
entity as a database table we'll start
by creating an entity called hippo that
uses the entity decorator
now because we have synchronized set to
true type ORM will automatically migrate
this model to the database and sync it
up every time we run the application now
we need to add some columns to it
starting with a primary key this value
needs to be unique and the easiest way
to make it unique is to use the primary
generated column decorator this will
automatically increment the ID for each
new record you add to the database so
one two three and so on from there we
can use the column decorator and Type O
RM will try to infer the type that we
use in typescript now types in SQL are
different than types in JavaScript so
you can manually set the SQL type by
passing it as the first argument to the
decorator and that's all it takes to
build a database table and model with
type ORM now let's perform some cred
operations on this model from our
functions code well go into the index TS
and import our connect helper as well as
the hippo entity now in this demo we're
just going to set up HTTP functions for
simplicity but you could also set these
up with callable functions or you could
even set them up with firestore
functions if you wanted to pass data
from firestore to your SQL database to
handle real-time features this first
function we're looking at here is called
get hippos and you'll want to make sure
that it's an async function the first
thing you'll do in any function with the
database is get the connection the
connection will allow you to interact
with the database in a variety of
different ways but one of the most
useful ways is with the repository API
this allows you to use one of your
entities as a starting point and then
make queries to update that entity or to
query it or join it with other entities
and all you have to do is pass in the
class name now if we want to query all
the rows from this database table we can
just call hippos find and that's just
one of the many methods that you'll find
on the repo to read and write to the
database and again the benefit of Type O
RM is that you have all of these really
easy to use methods instead of writing
in raw SQL queries although it is
possible to pass in some raw SQL with
the query method if you prefer we can
simply take the result of that read
and then Senate as the response from the
function and that will send it back to
the client as JSON so that function
allows us to read all the hippos in the
database but currently the database is
empty so we need another function to
write to it this next function is called
create hippo and it will create a new
hippo record based on the name and
weight passed in the request body from
the client when working with an async
function it's a good idea to set up a
try-catch block which will allow you to
catch errors and then send them back to
the client if necessary well go ahead
and set up the connection and make a
reference to the repository just like we
did in the previous function then this
time we'll create a new instance of the
hippo class and then we can set the
properties on that class to the data
that was passed in in the request body
and in the context of a real application
that data would likely come from a form
filled out on your website or from some
other mechanism in your front-end
application after those properties are
set we'll pass the class instance to the
save method
now these saved method might be
different than the hippo class because
you might have listeners on your
database that modified the record before
it actually gets committed to the
database so the data in the new hippo
variable might be different than the
data in the saved hippo variable so just
something to keep in mind there now
you'll want to make sure that you have
your sequel proxy running in the
background and then open up a new
terminal tab and run CD functions and
NPM runs serve this will serve the
functions locally and you should see
URLs to the local functions here which
you can copy and paste and then bring
those over to a rest client like
insomnia in the rest client we can set
up a new request that points to the get
hippos function if we make a call to
that function right now we should get an
empty array as the response and you may
have noticed that requests took two
seconds but don't worry it won't be that
slow in production it's just the
firebase functions emulator that makes
that slow now let's go ahead and point
to the create hippo function and this
time we'll pass in a JSON body with the
request and notice how there's no ID or
timestamp with the JSON body but when we
get the response back you can see an ID
has been automatically generated and we
also have a timestamp which is created
with a listener and I'll show you how to
do that in just a minute but for now
I'll go ahead and create a few more
hippo records and then we'll make
another query with our get hippos
function and now you see that all three
hippos are returned as an array of
objects from the cloud function
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what I want to show you next is how I'm
generating that created at timestamp
even though it's not a piece of data
that we're explicitly passing to the
database if we go back to our hippo
entity we'll go ahead and create another
column called created at and then we'll
use the before insert listener or hook
which allows us to run some code before
the item is actually inserted into the
database so this allows you to basically
hook into the lifecycle of the database
to run code after records created or
before which is another very powerful
feature of type ORM but if you're using
MySQL then you must likely want to take
advantage of its relational data
modeling features now if you remember
earlier I said hippos can have many hats
so we can create that relationship by
using the one-to-many decorator the
decorator takes two arguments the first
argument is a function that map's the
type for the relationship which is the
Hat entity that will create next and
that entity will have an owner property
that contains the ID of the hippo that
owns that hat because a hippo can own
many hats but a hat can only be owned by
one hippo at a time from there we'll
switch over to the Hat TS file which is
our hat entity the initial code for this
entity is basically identical and then
we have the second half of the
relationship which is many to one
between hats and hippos in this case it
will set up an actual database column
called owner which contains the foreign
key with the ID of the hippo that owns
that hat and what we've done here is set
up a relationship with two database
tables using minimal code now let's jump
back into our git hippos cloud function
and make a join query we still want to
query all the hippos in their database
but we also want to join all of their
hats from the separate database table
when we make that query we'll call
create query builder on the hippo repo
and then this is an example of a left
join basically we'll get all of the hats
that are owned by hippo and then join
the Hat entity data for each hippo
record and lastly we'll call get many to
return all the hats on that query that's
how we make the query but we also need a
way to create new hats because currently
there aren't any in the database this
function will look identical to the
create hippo function except it will
take the owner ID of a hippo and then
also the color of the Hat to create the
record at this point you can serve the
functions and then we'll go back over to
insomnia what I'm doing now is creating
a few new hat records in the database
and each one will be assigned to hippo
ID number one then if we go back and
they get hippos endpoint you can see
that it still retrieves all the hippo
records but it will also join the Hat
records to each one as well so we now
have a classic one-to-many relationship
in an SQL database within our firebase
project we've really just scratched the
surface of what's possible with type ORM
and MySQL but I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you want to learn how to build
awesome applications with firebase
consider becoming a pro member at fire
ship IO thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]